ce qui est bien quand on part à la
découverte de nouvelles contrées c'est
le dépaysement tout change les gens la
langue les modes de vie les paysages et
votre transit intestinal
tout l'été des tc vous aident à éviter
les pièges et les dangers qui menacent
votre bien-être et votre santé
dtc partenaire de votre été cet été si
vous voyagez vous aurez peut-être la
chance de découvrir cette petite
espièglerie qui pimente les séjours à
l'étranger qu'on appelle la turista
la lambada moi je parle de la touriste a
la diarrhée du voyageur
et si vous ne voyagez pas regarder la
vidéo quand même car c'est fort cocasse
[Applaudissements]
la diarrhée du voyageur la turista si
vous préférez si vous préférez façon de
parler c'est drôle non de classifier une
diarrhée en fonction de l'activité de la
personne qui la subit je veux dire ça
existe la diarrhée du pêcheur la
diarrhée du joggeur d'ailleurs ça n'est
pas le seul nom fleurit qu'on donne à la
turista on l'appelle aussi la complainte
de l'été la course de turquie la danse
aztèque le gallo grecque et cetera etc
moi j'aime bien mais bon on n'est pas là
pour déclamer du rimbaud on est là pour
parler chiasse alors allons-y la turista
c'est quoi alors contrairement à ce que
dit la légende la turista ça n'est pas
une réaction aux plats épicés et ça
n'est pas dû à un changement de régime
alimentaire
rien à voir non plus avec une
malédiction qui frapperait les étrangers
pour les éloigner d'un lieu sacré où
avec l'esprit des anciens qui se venge
du bétonnage de leurs terres ou que
sais-je
[Musique]
en réalité la turista 7 une intoxication
alimentaire ni plus une gastro entérite
aiguë c'est à dire une inflammation de
l'ensemble du tube digestif causés dans
la majorité des cas par un germe qu'on a
avalé parmi des bactéries en cause
au premier rang les bactéries fécales et
notamment les escherichia coli dont on
avait déjà parlé dans une vidéo
précédent je vous la remet en escrime
donc oui là on est en train de parler de
bactéries contenues dans le caca que
vous avalez j'ai conscience que savait
pas envie mais en fait on a beaucoup
plus de risque de choper la turista dans
les pays où le niveau d'hygiène et pas
elle se déclenche souvent dans les trois
premiers jours du voyage ou tout à la
fin parce qu'on croit qu'on est sortis
d'affaires alors on fait un peu moins
attention elle dure deux ou trois jours
parfois plus et autant vous dire que les
randos tourista les sports nautiques les
fesses serrées où les trajets en avion
c'est bof
alors le mieux c'est de prendre ses
précautions comment éviter la turista
alors c'est clair pour tout le monde
c'est au niveau de la nourriture et des
boissons que ça se passe mais pas que
voilà sept conseils pour éviter
vous voyez quoi la cuisson tue les
germes donc vérifier vos aliments sont
bien cuits et qui sont encore chauds
avant de les manger
évitez les crudités et si vraiment vous
voulez manger des fruits
épluchez les ne buvait que des boissons
en bouteille encapsulé et vérifiez bien
le bruit qu'ils font quand vous les
ouvrez ne prenez pas de glaçons parce
que c'est de l'eau du robinet à tous les
coups et éviter les glaces et les sort
mais aussi les oeufs et les produits
laitiers risque de contenir des germes
bien costaud dans des salmonelles donc
laissé tomber
brossez vous les dents avec de l'eau en
bouteille ou emmener des produits pour
désinfecter l'eau avant et éviter de
laisser couler de l'eau dans votre
bouche grande ouverte quand vous prenez
la douche je sais que l'actuel super
important lavez vous les mains le plus
souvent possible et éviter de les mettre
dans votre bouche ou dans la bouche de
qui que ce soit et quand c'est trop tard
on fait quoi
alors on fait quoi bah mon chien on se
perd dans un premier temps et puis on va
chercher une nouvelle luc nadal sur ebay
ou deux joueurs peu près mais surtout la
première chose à faire c'est de boire
beaucoup
identité un pur pas mais souvent pour
pas se déshydrater
oui de l'eau un bien sûr et de l'eau en
bouteille vous êtes déjà en mode coulées
de lave
vous n'allez pas en rajouter de l'eau en
bouteille il faut manger aussi pas trop
mais il faut manger essentiellement du
riz et des bananes si vous voulez en
attendant que ça se passe comme vous
êtes prévoyant ben vous avez emporté des
médicaments c'est le moment de les
prendre il y en a plusieurs types les
anti diarrhéiques les anti-infectieux
intestinaux les pansements gastriques
parlez-en à votre médecin avant de
partir est passé chez le pharmacien
après si les symptômes s'aggravent
si vous avez beaucoup de fièvre s'il ya
du sang dans votre cas qu'à aller voir
un médecin
bon ça je suis presque sûr que vous
auriez pensé tout seul mais ce qui va
sans dire va encore mieux en le disant
et puis une fois que le plus dur est
derrière vous redoublez de vigilance
mais ça c'est pareil je suis sûr que
vous avais pas très envie que ça
recommence voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui je vous souhaite un très bel
été plein de plein de joie et
d'allégresse
on se retrouve dans deux semaines pour
une nouvelle vidéo spécialités d'ici là
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]